la tragédie est dans tous les esprits de
toutes les conversations
un membre de la cit est tombé sous les
coups de couteau d'un autre enfant du
quartier hier soir un peu plus tôt une
jeune femme avait semble-t-il été prise
pour cible par la victime j'ai vu sa
lutte est décédé arriver mais il était
très en colère sociale des coquilles
esparros eleven directement métropole le
coup de vent il m'a fait c'est pas ôter
aux essais de la khl a commencé à
m'étrangler md ou qui meurent ce soir
montferrand et qui les cherchent ont
pesé et ensuite séchés puis à celui qui
a acheté il aceh pourquoi il était né en
vue comme ça ce jeune homme y avait déjà
eu des comptes ils ont décidé de les
laisser l'aide pas aussi à l'aller
viande en ligne ou et je pense que c'est
ça qui est ça la salle lui a fait mal en
fait simon jo hachadi tupac laisse
derrière lui un fils de 15 ans il venait
de passer quatre ans derrière les
barreaux pour ses proches c'était un bon
garçon même s'il avait noté des
changements dans son comportement
c'était un bon gars il travaille bien
avec moi dans la banane tous et puis je
ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé mais je
veux ça fait un petit moment il a changé
un barreau de grasse et et c'est un vrai
d'où le haut du tableau et on y croise
hérisser les croyants dans l'embarras et
puis moi un email
et à dolisie yaniv combiné à dallas
olivier bajard y passe en tête ni une
deuxième famille est brisée dans la cité
celle de steve mandanda 31 ans l'auteur
présumé des coups mortels
sai baba fils yogi l'ours et le bol d'or
il a cherché ces balles le g lui a
cherché dans le quartier des voix
s'élèvent aujourd'hui pour crier plus
jamais ça
ces deux familles
et des personnes qu'ils s'aimaient mais
un moment donné c'était un moment donné
c'était de l'amour et après c'était là
c'est lan - il faut qu'il faut arrêter
il faut arrêter faut que tout le monde à
séguinaud faut nous faudra nous pas les
mailles la faute à nous pas les âmes
appel à la raison afin que le calme et
la sérénité reprennent enfin leurs
droits dans la cité